biology is the subject that studies life
in all of its forms the most basic unit
and the foundation of all life is the
cell they're incredibly complicated
molecular factories and cellular biology
studies the structure and functions of
the many different things inside a cell
cells were evolving for over 3 billion
years until multicellular animals
appeared
that's over two-thirds of the age of the
earth so no wonder they're so
complicated cells are the smallest
things that we think can be counted as
life unfortunately there isn't a good
definition of life that everyone agrees
on
for example viruses evolve and replicate
but they need other life to do so are
they alive sort of but not really
molecular biology looks into the insides
of cells and studies how the different
systems work with each other on a
molecular basis it looks at DNA RNA
amino acids and the creation of proteins
how they interact with each other what
effects these interactions this is
related to structural biology which
looks at the shape of biological
molecules like amino acids nucleic acids
and enzymes why they have these
structures and how differences in their
structure affects how they work
biochemistry goes one step even deeper
and looks at how these biological
molecules interact with each other on a
chemical level life is essentially a
load of complex chemical reactions and
biochemistry studies the underlying
chemical signals and reactions of life
the molecules of life are too small to
see with optical microscopes and so many
techniques in physics like x-ray
crystallography or Kryon electron
microscopy are used to see the structure
of biomolecules as well as tools for
studying life biophysics and quantum
biology also look at the physics that
underpins biological processes seeking
to explain how things work on a physical
level your DNA holds the blueprint of
who you are and genetics is the study of
how DNA is expressed to create all of
the different forms of life through
genes and how this information is passed
on from one generation to the next
population genetics looks at the genetic
differences within a species and how
species differ from one another
the DNA code of an organism is huge and
so we need computers to find patterns in
the data bioinformatics is the subject
that uses computer programming to
analyze and interpret biological data in
genetics and also many other fields
wherever the amount of data is too large
to analyze with previous statistical
methods biomathematics uses the tool of
mathematics to build models of
biological processes and is used in many
different areas from genetics to
biotechnology to studying ecosystems you
started off as a single cell however
that cell divided and grew into you is
studied by developmental biology an
interesting area in developmental
biology is the growth in differentiation
of stem cells into the different cells
in your body anatomy looks at the
structure and organization at the scale
of entire organisms it includes both
plants and animals and seeks to label
all the different components that make
up an organism biomechanics looks at how
parts of the body are designed for
movement the most obvious is the
articulation of our limbs but it also
includes the flow of fluids or the
mechanical properties of bones or
tissues like the valves in our heart at
the microscopic level it also looks at
the strength or flexibility of cells or
parts of cells
well anatomy studies what organisms are
made of physiology studies how these
parts work and interact with each other
it seeks to understand how all of the
different components in an organism work
together to keep it functioning normally
immunology studies our immune system how
it protects us from infection in a
multitude of ways it also investigates
the many different ways our immune
system can go wrong
allergies autoimmunity where your immune
system attacks your own body to wider
conditions like cancer many other
illnesses the increased lifespan of
humans has been helped significantly by
biomedical research trying to find ways
to tackle the causes of illnesses and
death
this spans many areas from basic
research to developing new medical
devices new ways of finding and
diagnosing illnesses or developing new
drugs through clinical trials in
pharmaceutical industry bioengineering
takes the principles of engineering and
the knowledge of biological systems and
mashes them together to solve real world
this can be used to make devices to help
in medicine like artificial organs which
is called biomedical engineering and it
can be used to create biotechnology like
genetic engineering where the genetic
code of organisms is modified to tackle
diseases or for example to make crops
that are resistant to challenging
growing conditions synthetic biology is
another branch of bioengineering where
scientists can make organisms that don't
occur in nature by making new sequences
of DNA from scratch or redesigning
existing systems like genetically
engineering ecoli to perform useful
tasks like making drugs or targeting
delivery of drugs in the body it's worth
pointing out that all of the subjects on
this map are very interrelated most of
them draw upon many of the other areas
in their research a good example is
neuroscience the study of the nervous
system and especially the brain it
involves the anatomy of the brain the
physiology of neurons as well as
molecular biology and biochemistry
inside the brain so in biology as well
as with most of science there's a lot of
cross-pollination between fields
pharmacology studies the effects drugs
have in the body he looks at many
aspects of drugs how to make them what
to make them from and their effect in
different biological systems
pharmacology is related to pharmacy
which is the science of preparing and
dispensing drugs pathology is the study
of causes and effects of diseases and
the diagnosis of disease through taking
samples from the body like blood or
tissue
it also looks at how cells adapt to
injury the healing of wounds
inflammation or abnormal growth of new
cells like with cancer it's also used to
investigate how people have died using
post-mortem examinations epidemiology
looks at health and disease in whole
populations and looks at the patterns of
disease how its transmitted and the
effects on the overall health of a
population diseases are monitored all
the time and if there's an outbreak
epidemiologists swoop in to work out how
it's spreading and try to mitigate the
damage taking a wider view biology
includes the study of the entire natural
world looking at the deep past we get
paleontology the study of prehistoric
life looking at fossils to work out what
ancient creatures look like and how they
evolved
it's closely related to evolutionary
biology which looks at how all of the
life on Earth originated from a single
common ancestor and studies how
evolution led to the wide diversity of
life on Earth the many plants and
animals that live on the earth today
fall under the study of zoology marine
biology and botany these look at animals
plants and fungi their development
behavior physiology how to classify all
of the different species ecology looks
at how whole groups of animals and
plants interact with each other in an
environment our animals compete or
cooperate with each other and how many
different kinds of plants and animals
inhabit the same environment this is
closely related to environmental biology
which looks at how ecosystems can be
thrown off balance by humans through
pollution agriculture or our fossil fuel
emissions causing changes to
environments and the climate so far the
only life we've seen in the universe
exists on earth but are we the only
planet in the universe with life on it
or are there other planets out there
with their own strange forms of life
astrobiology is our attempt to answer
this question to work out how life may
arise from chemical reactions and to
probe distant planets and moons for
signs of life if there's one word that
describes biology its complexity there's
a huge amount we still don't understand
about how life works how it started and
how it ended up with intelligent apes
like us who are able to look back and
try and work it all out I feel like
we'll be making new biological
discoveries for many many years to come
and if you just discovered this video
please consider subscribing it really
helps my channel grow and get these fun
explainers out to more people I've got
many more videos like this and I've put
together a playlist which you can watch
here and if you'd like to get your hands
on a poster of this video check out the
links in the description below and
finally if you need a present for a
youngster in your life check out my
professor Astro cap books which are
awesome and available in all good book
drops around the globe in many many
different languages okay thank you bye